have you ever seen the government
ever work this hard to silence people
and keep them in line i've never seen it
if they thought we were sheep
if they thought we couldn't stop it they
wouldn't care they wouldn't do any of
this but they are working over
overtime
and they're talking now of probably
about at least 50 percent of the country
remember to change things it only it's
the tipping point is like 19 or 20
percent
they're talking about half of the nation
that's pretty significant and they know
it
what can people do like would you
recommend people actually take their
money out of chase and put it in the
local federal credit union in their city
i mean is that that's probably a small
step 100
that's a big step
because if all of our audiences did that
it would shake the financial markets
they would be like wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute how much money have
you lost
because that's the money that they are
using and by the way
after september i'm sorry after um uh 08
and the banking collapse
the laws were changed the money you have
in your checking and savings
you are the depositor of last resort so
you can't go get your money if they say
you know there's a banking crisis we
need all the money we can get you have
zero access to the money you're the last
uh uh debtor that they need to pay
you're not the first so
i'm not giving my money to these big
financial institutions you go to your
local credit union
make sure that everything is i can't
remember the acronym for the fdic for uh
right there's a separate one yeah a
separate one but you make sure that it's
insured and you put everything there
it's so critical that we are not taking
money our money loaning money giving
money to these banks that are then
spreading it all over america and the
news that broke last week all over the
world
instead we must keep it local we have to
strengthen our local communities our
local businesses
so best way to do it and i would do it
today take your money and tell them why
i'm not going to be in a a bank that is
involved and has esg scores i'm going to
a local credit union do it today
so speaking of things that you can do
today we're all watching you know the
supply chain stuff and it took me i
moved to florida a month ago it took the
truck
literally five weeks to get here because
the truck with all my stuff just came
this week because they can only get
trucks to drive one way because in a
normal time trucks are going both ways
with stuff they can and they also can't
get drivers anymore and the price of gas
went up
and the supply chain you can't get stuff
to build out and say a house or a studio
and everything else do we just need to
build a parallel economy at every level
and i mean from banks to
to a new home depot to just the whole
damn thing we're gonna have to buy our
own candy shops and you you start by um
putting your money into a local bank and
just realize it's the george bailey
savings and loan
you know it has to stay local they are
mr potter that is the best movie to
explain the great reset you know he
looks at people just as you know they're
bums and they're never gonna get
anywhere so he'll take their money and
he'll build potterville and that is what
they're building in the western world is
potterville can i ask you one question
dave sure
what are you doing with bitcoin i put my
money in bitcoin and i'm like let it
ride
but now with the treasury
the the fed the imf
they are going to kill these things
what are you doing are you leaving it in
or are you taking it out yeah so i have
a chunk of bitcoin not not not a ton but
i have several bitcoin and i'm just
leaving it i've never touched any of it
and i just wanted to sit there and see
what happens i actually was going to ask
you in a few minutes about you know
biden now wants to regulate bitcoin
which is the whole purpose of a
decentralized coin a whole decentralized
system is to not be regulated and you
can see obviously anyone watching this
can understand why that would be
separate that's the off ramp for this
insanity i think people have to have it
you have to be able to diversify because
if they come for you if what you're
laying out here is right and by and
large i think it is it's like you're
going to need some other ways to to have
commerce with people you're going to be
able when the [ __ ] hits the fan i mean
you're going to need to be able to trade
goods and services with people and that
that's where crypto comes in so that's
where i go to
um you know i i live
here in the city in dallas
but if crap starts to hit the fan i've
got another house in a very small
farming community and that's where i'm
planning on on being with my family and
friends is in this really small
tight-knit community
and we're right now working on you know
the farmers market
we are talking to each other hey what do
you have in your tool shed
that can make things you know what do
you have and so we're not
buying the same things
that we can share if things really get
bad that we can fix everything that we
need that's the kind of stuff that um i
think we really need to look at um be
are you in a community of like-minded
people that will help each other because
dave there's something else that i touch
on in the book
this what's so insidious about this is
i have been talking since probably 1995
there is a new
industrial revolution that is coming
that will be as profound as the
industrial revolution but it when it
starts it will happen in a 10-year
period not a hundred years
well we're there we're already i think i
think we're year two in that industry of
the fourth industrial revolution
and by 2030 40 of jobs are going to be
gone
maybe there'll be some new things but
probably not um that's why we're talking
about you know basic universal income
and everything else because tech knows
what is coming and now so do our
politicians
um the one thing that
we are that everybody is pushing us the
opposite direction that we have to
recognize stop and go the other way
is empathy
the only thing that a.i cannot duplicate
is empathy if you're looking to tell
your kids what kind of job are you going
to get
you you'd be really wise to say forget
about school or whatever if you if you
want to be a nurse
go to school not a doctor a nurse go to
school and make sure you focus
everything on empathy because
the ai is gonna tell you everything
that's going on in that person
you have to be the one that is the face
that comes in and says it's all right
everything is all right it's going to be
okay
because ai cannot do that
um that's where its hole is
also if a if the world is run by a.i or
people that you know just think of other
people as sheep
um
gosh
they are missing all empathy
and that's a pretty dark world what's
crazy is
uh
in many ways
the liberals were right
we were wrong we thought it would come
as you know some
communist marxist thing those guys are
being used this is coming through our
corporations
every time i watch a dystopian movie i
roll my eyes and they're like i work for
the corporation aka the government i'm
like ah stop it
that is what they're right and how the
left is i i'm against big pharmaceutical
companies
really except for right now when it
counts
i mean it's crazy they knew all this
stuff we mocked them and now we're
standing where they were going guys
uh you were right i mean
can't you see this
but you gotta kind of admire it right
like not what it's doing but the trick
that it pulled right there you got to
admire it that these people you've got
as you're saying they're the pawns these
communists and socialists and all these
people they're the pawns and the foot
soldiers and they think that they're
against the power while they literally
are for all the corporations they're for
all of the messaging i walk into target
yesterday to buy some cleaning supplies
and there is a massive black lives
matter section there and it's like
you're fighting the power really with
that shirt and sweatshirt and pants and
shoes i think in a hundred years dave
this is going to be studied in every
government
program
uh that is you know
trying to teach about the history and
government and behavioral science
this is
this is the time that the world will
look back i think we're going to be
studied for a thousand years
especially
if we defeat it
no nation has ever defeated anything
like this
i think we could be
the exception to that rule but only if
we all wake up
don't go down the road of conspiracies
just get the actual facts because
they're worse than any anybody that
could come up with conspiracies online
these are true
and if you just
do that remain calm work on empathy
don't play into their hands
we beat them and here's why i know this
have you ever seen the government
ever work this hard
to silence people and keep them in line
i've never seen it
if they thought we were sheep if they
thought we couldn't stop it they
wouldn't care they wouldn't do any of
this but they are working over overtime
and they're talking now of probably
about at least 50 percent of the country
remember to change things it only it's
the tipping point is like 19 or 20
percent
they're talking about half of the nation
that's pretty significant and they know
it
do you think that the default position
of humanity is to cower
that in that in these moments it seems
like it's a lot easier
to cower right i mean even now like
that's the thing when people say this to
me about
how do i get brave or whatever it's like
we live in the freest place in the
history of the world bravery and if
you're if you're afraid now imagine the
second that thing gets turned a little
bit
how afraid you're gonna be so it seems
like
like fear and and i'm sure there's a
psychological component to this that
fear does something in the brain that
may be bravery or
or maybe it really is about just knowing
what you are and what you're making let
me tell you two stories um
uh first fear
shuts your brain down okay it shuts
reason down you're in fight or flight
and that's a good thing because you
don't want to be going well i don't know
should i hit him a little harder you're
just
swinging so
fear and anger really bad and that's why
we're addicted outrage we will swing you
got to get shake that or you won't think
it's biological
two stories um
the other person we met with in poland
was the chief rabbi
and he said i think it was seven
thousand there were seven thousand
people that stood
and i was
i mean when have you been auschwitz no i
haven't when you go there's churches i
mean a block away there are houses
everywhere and they're old they were
there and
i left there and i was enraged i
remember
crying and and looking at the houses and
screaming in my head
where the hell were you
where were you
i meet with him and i said
how out of all the millions of people
and he said
you're thinking that's a small number
you said that's an incredible number of
people
people
you're in a scary movie
you look away
when something like this is coming it is
human nature to look away
or to dismiss
and you it's it's it's um we have this
gift of fear
that
warns us
but we use logic and sometimes we use it
just to protect ourselves because dave i
don't think people are afraid
of standing
i think they're afraid of knowing the
truth
you
look at the people who stand the people
who stand are the ones who are going you
know i learned something new
i learned something it's changed me
they're not standing you're not standing
because you're brave and i'm going to
take a stand you're saying wait a minute
i just scales fell off my eyes i just
learned something
when you are inquisitive
when you are based in wait a minute i i
really want to know
you have already prepared to
yeah but do you really
you and i i know you know this i think
we've talked about it i went through it
and you went through it you do come to a
point to where you're saying
if i take another step
everything in my life could change my
friends might change they might look at
me differently
and you take that step and say yeah i
want to know the truth
that's where people fail
they if you can't take that leap
and that's why i really think you're
seeing people like you
you're seeing the inquisitive
because that's in their nature to
question question wait a minute that
doesn't make sense that doesn't make
sense and if you're like that you most
likely have already passed that line of
uncomfortability
because you've had things you realized
and you went oh crap okay well
i guess i don't believe that anymore
yeah and i just don't know how i could
wake up and put stuff in my hair and
look in the mirror and go that's why i
just don't know how i could do it but i
know some people do it and then i get i
think this is what jordan would describe
as sort of the slow road to hell you
will just diminish yourself and diminish
yourself every every day of your life
until the end just you have to stop
looking you have to turn around because
it will always
present you with the option oh you saw
it you looked out and you saw them just
lining up a family of jews shooting them
okay
now what do you do
once you see it
it presents you with the choice
do i go back to sleep or do i stand
so
i know every you know it's very easy to
always be like okay both sides are going
crazy they're equally horrible and all
of those things like that's sort of like
the easy the easy way of doing it i'm
not saying that's that's what you're
doing here but that's sort of the easy
way to do it and we all fall in that
trap sometimes right because just for
brevity's sake sometimes it's easier to
say that
but it seems to me that for all the
people that that absolutely despise
trump that that hate everything about
the right the right basically has been
in power for the last two years there's
a lot of good things happening in the
country related to economics and the
fact that we're not entering foreign
wars and there's some interesting things
happening with north korea and a series
of other things and the state has not
used its power to silence anyone what i
fear
and this is why i don't think it's an
even oh both sides are crazy thing is
that the left is about state
power and what i fear is they've said
well half of the country is nazis we
cannot be civil with them because
they're coming to get us and if these
people took power
well now we have everything that you
just laid out because they don't mind
using the apparatus of the state right
to accomplish their goals and i'm not
saying republicans are always right
about this stuff and they they screw up
all the little government things that
they should care about and all of that
the left has become everything they said
the tea party was
okay that we weren't we weren't
um they have become violent they have
become unreasonable they want to silence
people and they will silence people
that's why you're seeing people start
begin to stand up and say
um
however
it's one of my fears with donald trump
and the great thing is he says a lot
and most of it never happens you know
what i mean
my fear is
um he has said you know maybe we should
look into the license of these companies
you know i don't think he means it
but you signal that to people
on the right or the left you're you're
basically saying yeah that's on the
that's on the field
of play it's not on the field of play
um although there's an interesting
libertarian argument whether the
government should be giving licensing no
no i don't think they should have
license at all right right i don't i
certainly don't want the government to
say you know what you've been a little
harsh so i'm going to look into your
life no right not at all get them out of
that here's the here's the thing that
people aren't thinking about
government
is about to become
[Music]
unless it marries into it
pretty inconsequential because it will
never be able to keep up with technology
so is that the saving grace here no
not not that i was going to give google
a lot of the left is concentrating their
power in silicon valley
and
that's where you can really silence
people the guy who wrote
ibm and the holocaust
gosh i can't remember his name
really brilliant guy well thought out
we were talking and
talking about how
the germans how they silence people and
how they they cordoned people off and
then just get smaller and smaller groups
and then they eventually put you behind
a wall
in a ghetto
well
they would build the wall higher and
higher so people couldn't hear or see
that what google and facebook are doing
we're building digital ghettos
we have the ability now you can speak
all you want dave
but i'm changing the algorithm and
you're not going to be heard
i mean
you look at what the deal with facebook
was
i promote them
i give them my
10 million listeners and i say hey you
can find me at facebook
let's communicate
then they take those listeners that said
i want to hear from him
and then they change the algorithm and i
can't communicate to my own people
i went to um auschwitz and i brought my
kids 2012.
and we were going to
israel for a vacation and i was bringing
the whole family and i said you can't go
to israel for the first time
unless you pass through the gates of
auschwitz first
and my wife said
honey that doesn't make it really a
vacation and i said
i want the kids to understand why israel
is there and i want them to make a
choice now when they're young
who are you going to be
if the world goes insane who will you be
and i i
a a woman she was oh in her 80s and
so sweet
she was one of the righteous among the
nations which are the christians that
saved jews
and we went through auschwitz and then
we met with her
and
as we were leaving she told us this she
sat down with the family for like an
hour it was just amazing
and she told us how
at 16 years old she saw a jew on the
street
just starving you could only feed a jew
i think 400 or 800 calories a day
and
just starving and it was a girl her age
and she said please do you have any food
she said i don't but if you come here
tomorrow i'll bring you something
so she came she sat down at the dinner
table that night with her mom and dad
and they were eating dinner
and this is a death sentence you feed
the jew you get the same thing it's a
death sentence and she said mom and dad
i have to tell you something she said i
promised i would bring some food
tomorrow to this jewish girl who was
starving
and she said she remembers the whole
room just stopping and her mom and dad
putting their spoon down
and looking at each other and staring at
each other not saying anything
and then her mom got up she started
pulling
a big pot out
and put it on the stove and paulina said
what are you doing mom she said
well if she's coming for food she'll
clearly have hungry friends
they saved about 100
jews
so after i talked to her i said to her
paulina
what do you
how do i water the seed of righteousness
in myself and in my family what do you
do to strengthen that that seed is there
how do we make it into a tree so we
stand
and she looked at me and said something
that i thought was profound but up until
recently i've never tr i didn't truly
understand
and she said
you you misunderstand
the righteous didn't suddenly become
righteous they just refuse to go over
the cliff with the rest of humanity
that's fantastic
we don't have to do you don't ever have
to get to von stauffenberg okay all you
have to do is say no that's crazy i know
what i saw that's a car burning behind
you that's antifa that's a riot that's
looting that's wrong right mostly
peaceful yeah it's not mostly peaceful
i'm sorry you're going over the cliff
into insanity i'm standing where i've
always stood
you know it's interesting i i often
think now now that i've been taking some
of these positions that aren't thought
of as popular or or
okayed by mainstream or whatever that
the only thing to fear is fear itself
and i've been thinking about that a lot
lately that the more that i say the
things that i believe to be true that
happen to be against the mainstream
things
the more i get over that because if you
can get over the fear then if it's true
that we're on a list and they're coming
for us then we're on a list then we're
on a list and by the way pretty much
everyone's on the list and that's why
there's that famous thing you know they
came for the jews first it's like we're
all we're all part of this thing but
it's a very strange time that you can
show me some of these things
founding documents from the united
states
documents about saving jews during world
war ii and it feels like something
that's kinda now
only if people don't find their courage
yeah i truly believe
and this is why i think you're so
powerful
courage is contagious it is
people not everybody's a leader not
everybody's willing to step out into
danger
you know
not everybody's willing to lose all
their friends or to whatever
but when they see someone
risk everything
and they see them
on a list
if you can get them early enough
they'll step out but the longer you wait
the worse it gets that's bonhoeffer was
a pacifist was involved in vlad
staffenberg's uh coup
how he's a pacifist
he
he said there's nothing else we can do
at this point because it's too late the
people's hearts had turned to stone and
you couldn't turn them
we have to find a way to make sure that
our hearts and the hearts of everybody
we know
stay soft and see people as people not
enemies you know when i was on tour with
jordan one of the things that he would
bring up often because he would talk
about the parallels to nazism to some of
the authoritarian movements of the day
and he would say to everyone in the
crowd he'd say you know there's three
thousand of you sitting out here right
now
and i guarantee you that every single
one of you
would think that you wouldn't be a nazi
if this was 1936 germany and that proves
probably
that you would be
and i always thought that that was
pretty powerful we all think we would do
the unpopular thing we all think we
would do the the risky thing we all
judge everybody by our standards of
today i'm not sure i'd stand in the end
i mean
a friend of mine marcus trell
i said to him
how do you stand torture and not break
and he said glenn
everyone breaks
everyone breaks
he said
but the ones who break the fastest and
the loudest are the ones who will say
i'm never i'll stand oh i'll stand
because they haven't
thought about it it's why i wanted to
bring my kids to auschwitz i need you to
feel it
so you can think about it and really
look at this as a possibility and once
you do that and you realize
by the grace of god i'll stand
um
then you're then you're ready
but we we have got to prepare ourselves
now
to be ready because if you're ready now
the problems go away
they think you're sheep
i mean i asked you on a podcast with you
the last time where's the line
what line do you have as an individual
that you say
i won't cross
well i i won't go there i mean
if i said to you last summer yeah
they're going to tell us that we can't
have thanksgiving with our family
that we have to wear a mask all the time
and the president's going to make that
mandate and they're going to shut down
the economy you and i and everybody else
would have said never
never i would have said you know maybe
they're right about that bad guy yeah
right
you would have you would have it's
insane to think look where we are
and now all of a sudden that's normal
it's the new normal
yeah they get you with that phrase the
new normal because there's there's an
implicit oh accept it
it's implicitly
it's here so you better accept it so the
thing about war is
war is just about changing
leadership borders and financial systems
that's what war is really about for the
people up at the top
and it's usually so horrible
that
a society even great ones never go back
to the way they were
because
you're so willing to accept peace
i just want to go back to normal that
you never reset back to normal and
you'll accept almost anything
here we are
look at what we're willing to accept at
this point and i know i did when they
started talking about the new normal i
was like no no i don't no no no i don't
want a new normal i want normal normal
yeah regular normal will be just fine
yeah how many people now would just be
happy if we just if we had okay this is
a new normal and they're gonna start you
know letting letting things back up but
it's never going to get the way it was
lots lots would accept that i want to
talk to you about taking that time off
and and i want to explore what you just
said how people look crazy because i
think we are going into some sort of an
insanity
with all this but i just want to give
i want to give the audience a sneak peek
and you they will know the answer to
this if they've been paying attention
but you will have no idea and as i was
preparing last night i thought
i could read these headlines if i had
been unplugged i could read these
headlines and i would have absolutely no
idea which was true and which was false
okay all right
two truths and a lie oh okay so i'll
give you two headlines that are true
one is a lie i'm going to do two sets of
yes which i want you to guess i'm not
going to tell you uh we'll reveal it
here it's a little rusty related to
reality right now okay all right
headline number one yeah
trump wants to buy greenland
headline number two
trump suggests we nuke the hurricane
and headline number three
aoc triggered over a cardboard cutout
well that one sounds real to me that one
definitely sounds real to me um
before i give you the answer i just have
to say one thing about trump because
when you're off the grid
you realize that not everyone is talking
about trump no one almost no one is well
the funny thing is so for a couple of
the days so i really even though i
wasn't online doing things i was working
in my own way and as you know my my book
got released right before i left and i
was doing things related to that and
editing and a bunch of other stuff but
for a couple of days we went away and we
were at this resort and i'm you know
doing the beach thing and in the
mornings they would give all the people
a sheet of paper with the news
in whatever language people said the
french one italian english one and the
only thing i saw all month was i just
saw two words trump vows and then i
looked away and and i just thought
whatever it is vows to
blow up greenland or buy greenville no
buy greenland blow up the hurricanes
yeah blow up hurricanes whatever it is
it's like man like it'll it'll happen
whether i pay attention or not so to
answer your question well the cardboard
cutout triggering aoc that sounds very
legit to me right which could be
trump trick trump saying he's gonna blow
up a hurricane sounds like the type of
thing that he would say right to trigger
the entire media and then make it sound
like he thinks he can blow up hurricanes
okay and then the other one was that he
said he's gonna buy greenland yeah
that's funny to me that one sounds like
the hurricane one sounds so stupid that
i think it's real the aoc one sounds
within pretty much yeah yeah
so you're going so i'm going trump
buying green trump buying greenland is
false is false okay we'll come back to
that here a second
you're not going to tell them not to
tell you again okay
the second second one study finds humans
are biased against robots of color
uh headline number two trans activist
jessica yaniv do you remember her yeah
yeah i think there she was uh trans
activist jessica
yanev tweets she can't go into the pool
today because her period started and she
forgot her tampons
or headline number three
nyu gender studies department says
milking cows
is like sexual assault and raping cows
which one is real
fast these are all real that's what it
sounds like to me but
oh god um
the jessica you need one because that
that story about
this
that sounds right to me like that sounds
within the realm of the insanity that
that thing had been about so i'll write
it down
all right uh give me what was the first
one uh the first one was uh the jessica
yeniv i think uh no no it was um
a study finds humans are biased
on robots of color yeah that sounds
legit to me there's definitely going to
be robot racism coming through and so
it's the nyu study that says milking
cows is akin to rape
god that sounds real too ah i'm gonna
i'm gonna say milking cows okay all
right all right so now you just say the
name glenn beck you just say your name
people go completely bananas one way or
another yeah
how does that feel i don't deserve
either of them yeah i don't deserve the
the vitriolic hate and i don't deserve
the
the adoration
it's weird
because
because a i don't feel like i deserve
either of them
but
i'm willing to take
the bad i'm willing to
um
sit and listen to the people who have
the bad to say about me because some of
it i understand their perspective some
of it i made huge mistakes
just wrong on
but i'm willing to take my share of what
has what we're now living
and in hopes
that
other people will go
okay wait a minute what what have i done
to
even just a facebook post yeah what am i
doing to contribute to
the incivility that we have i had a
bigger platform
but
we all have one
yeah well i'm glad you mentioned a
facebook post because now we live in a
time where if someone absolutely hates
you or absolutely loves you and as you
said you may not deserve either one of
those
they can get to you like immediately is
is that great or is it maddening or it's
both probably no if it's reasoned yeah
it's fantastic i mean
i've done radio this is
uh in march will be my 40th year in
broadcast i've done it for 40 years
when i did it to get into radio you had
to have a test and get a license i mean
it was it was hard to get a job and
there's only a small pool of people that
could do it
now
everybody has the same voice if you have
something that is appealing there's no
gates you have to go through you can now
you can now write the president you can
tweet
he might read it
and retweet it right okay so everybody
has the opportunity
to
have their voice heard that is
miraculous and a chance for me to
write to the president or to elon musk
or anybody and have them respond to me
is truly remarkable yeah what we're
missing is
but because you have that power it also
requires
responsibility
and
um
because i did radio for 40 years
and my
radio world view was really shaped
during the beginnings of howard stern
and i mean the early washington before
anybody knew him howard stern
i was raised in that era of of stunting
and you know entertainment
and
what i did was i mixed the two
trouble trouble
and
uh
i didn't see a problem it was a natural
evolution
that has taught a whole generation of
that's the way you do it yeah not good i
remember watching you when you were on
fox news and you know you have the board
and you're drawing arrows everywhere
talking about the government's this and
god's here and people are replacing
government
and all this stuff and i remember being
half entertained half i was like wow
this guy is nuts i can't believe this is
on television
and then half going there's actual
information here so when you were when
you started doing that stuff did you was
that really the goal like i'm going to
do a little bit of everything and then
we'll figure out what the sauce is so my
my job as i saw it
um was
to get ratings that's my job to get
ratings
people forget that like that should be
overlooked right that at the end of the
day you have to get ratings you have to
get clicks how many people now
keep checking their facebook page to see
how many likes they get i mean moms at
home how many likes do i get right it's
the same thing and if you're not careful
you'll find yourself caught up in those
likes
early in my life out being an alcoholic
before i sobered up i'd do anything for
a rating point that drove me rating
point success money fame yeah i crashed
thank god for that crash or i would have
probably still be at fox and i'd be a
monster
but the crash taught me
that
that
can help you on goals don't let it
control you
so yes my first part my job
was to get ratings right but that was
just a vehicle for me to be able to have
my point of view and perspective and my
perspective
was
the early 20th century progressive is
extraordinarily dangerous
you may not
be that person today
but the roots are this and some are
still those people yeah okay
and that's what you were drawing really
a lot often talking about the role of
government a lot of the things that i
discussed on this show you were saying
it starts here correct and this is where
it's going to end correct and so
to you know i i did like three shows on
woodrow wilson and they were number one
yeah um beating prime time um i did
hayek a whole i think a week on hayek
which put
uh road to serfdom back on the top 10
new york times best seller list and it
was a rating success so
my job was how do i make it interesting
make it fun make it entertaining
and
really teach something that no one else
says can be taught on tv if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell